Hi, everyone. In this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at the foliage tool.
Now this is going to be an overview, as we have classes that specifically cover it in
more detail. But we're going to look at it in pertaining to building a world and
some of the tips and tricks that you should look out for when using the tool.
So let's go and jump right into Unreal and get started. One of the first things
I want to point out is we're inside of the levels folder here. And we're looking
at the in class speed building. Now we're going to be visiting this one later on.
But for foliage purposes, we're going to be painting foliage on this in this
particular scene. So once you have the scene loaded, you want to go to the
foliage tool underneath our pull down here where the class name is at, and
then go and select foliage. The hotkey for that is shift plus the number
three. Now you want to be able to load them. This is pretty simple when
working with these. If I simply just found where this one was at just as a
reference point, you can simply grab any new foliage type that you want to put in
here. And it's pretty simple and pretty easy to do. Once that's in place,
you will see a save the foliage if you change any of the settings
remaining, as well as an active tick mark area to be able to actually turn
these pieces of foliage on. Now you can shift select them if you want or
just Ctrl Shift and D select what you don't want. And you can also add the
foliage here. You can also search for any foliage that you might need at any
particular time. You will see a button here that says hide selected details. So
if you need to you can do some full of foliage, as well as some simple
settings that you can see for like thumbnails or a list if you want to
make things easier to view things overall. Now you'll notice when we have
the foliage selected, let's actually pick a couple here. I accidentally clicked on
the foliage plus there, but we don't need that right now. And let's turn on
this one. We'll turn on pretty much most things here. And again you can grab
them, shift select, and simply click on all and all of them that are selected
will appear and be able to be loaded to be able to be painted on. What I
do want to point out first up, you'll notice we have a brush size, we have a
paint density, and we have an erase density. So we can lower our density if
we don't want it too thick, maybe have it pretty low. And we'll look at a
comparison here. And in my painting tool with these items active, I can also
use the bracket tools to increase or decrease my size. Now these are pretty
standard stuff. If you're new to foliage painting, this will be new to you. If
you're not, this will be kind of a bit of a review for you. And you'll
notice as I'm painting, I'm getting the trees, everything else in between,
you're like, Oh, God, that is way too dense. And remember, we can isolate
based on what we need. And I'm hitting Ctrl Z there. We can also shift
unpaint here, I can shift left click to get that go to go away. But we
can control that density. So if we go into say, let's turn off everything
but the trees, because the trees are a good example of spread and thickness
here. And let's go and turn everything off. Let's shift select these and
turn them off. We'll turn the bush off too. And we'll just keep these
this set of oops, we'll keep this set of trees right here, these
three. Now you'll notice again, we're controlling paint density, so
we can lower that even more if we wanted to. We can also go over
here, though, and you'll notice there's a density here. Now
there's a difference between these. Now this is my paint
density here. And you'll notice on row gives us a hot tip
here to paint that gives us the overall density. And it
multiplies individual foliage type densities here in our
scene. But you'll notice also, this gives us our placement here
on our unit area. So I might want to lower this to to make
this like 0.002. Now you'll notice when you do that it is
dramatically different than what we had before. So I went
and changed both of those to give me a little bit better
advantage of painting. And this is so much easier and
works a bit better. But you'll notice is if I keep
painting, because of my distance, it's still going to
try to crowd a few things, because I just need to be more
selective when I'm painting. If I just simply click, I can
get it into place. But I can also choose to just have it as
a single painting option if I needed to. Now you'll notice
there's a single button here. And that allows me just to
paint one tree at a time. And sometimes that can be
pretty helpful. You can say, Hey, I just want to paint
as where you click, it will paint the tree, which is
pretty convenient. And this looks a little bit more
realistic, like a forest, instead of smashing too many
things together. So I'm going to go ahead and increase my
brush size here and go to my regular painting. And I
keep my finger on the shift key, and then we can on paint
what we don't need. Now the nice thing about this too is
working with this tool, we can also select individual
pieces of trees with that individual selection tool. So if
it's too dense, maybe you did not create the radius
enough, or you painted quickly, and you had them
bunch up together, you can simply just sparse things out
by deleting those. Now don't be afraid when working with
these plants, you want to be able to actually make it so
you can control things a little more finite. Remember, I
said you can do it single and just paint them in. But
you can also at any time find where that piece of
geometry lives. And if it's a hero scene, or you want
to have a little more control, maybe you have a copy
that has a little more wind to it. For dramatic effect,
you can simply just drag it into the scene. But
remember, he will not be affected by your painting
options. We do this quite often or tell our clients to
do this when it comes to virtual production,
especially if you just want a little more finite control
of that particular tree, like you wanted it to
bend a particular way, have a particular visual
look to it, that's up to you. Now you'll notice
here as we select these I'm painting singularly. And
again, I can also shift select and switch to my
paint to get rid of those that we don't need.
Now remember, with the single, again, if we just
want to select here, let's just isolate here, we
can select whatever we need. And you'll notice
this these two guys are getting punched up right.
So you can move them into the ground or move
them out. And this helps with actually navigating
such as hillsides, you'll notice our PCG is
sticking a tree out on the side. Now we don't
have it fully implemented yet to be able to
select individual pieces for PCGs. We'll go over
this later. But we we are going to be looking at
it so we can have a little bit more finite
control. So just be careful when you paint, you
can control some of the positioning here too.
Well, you'll notice we have a ground pitch angle
we can control and align a max angle so you
can adjust some of these if you need to, and
align to normal now, as well as average normal.
So these things can be options when you come
across those hard angles, or just be careful to
avoid them. But you do have an adjustment there,
if you need. Now, one thing you do want to
keep in place, and this is kind of an old
school methodology, but you want to make sure
that in your mobility, you set it to movable
for all your foliage, because this is going to
make things work a bit better, especially when
it comes to say, you want interactivity, you
want the wind to blow, you want those things
to be active, you want to set that to
movable. In the past and Unreal, if you did
not set those accordingly, you would get like
blurry effects with ray tracing. And in our
case, we should be fine. But you do want to
make it so that stuff is manageable and
movable. As you move things in your scene.
Now we're going to get into landscape a little
bit more later. And we'll talk about some of
the options you have to be able to build
things out. But this is again, this is a quick
overview of what you can do with your scene
and how to keep things in place. Now with
our new voxel system coming up for plants,
you're going to have it so the preserve
area option will still be an option within
the nanite object. But you'll also have
the ability to be able to adjust some of
the parameters when it comes to working
with their voxel shape. All right,
well, that's it with this video. In the
next video, we're going to take a look at
some more tools and aspects of building your
world that's really going to help you out.
Thanks again.